everyone in the U.S should be
self-employed at some level why do you
believe that you are 300 times less
likely to be audited by the IRS when you
have a business entity in place if you
show the intent to generate income and
to treat and operate as a business now
you open the doors to play by the rules
to utilize all of these additional
deductions
so according to lawsuit statistics in
the U.S there are about 40 million
lawsuits filed every year that is 76
lawsuits filed every minute and a newly
completed survey actually reveals that
small companies are overpaying on their
taxes by an average of almost twelve
thousand dollars and one in three small
businesses are overpaying on their taxes
in general so I'm super fired up for
this episode of the think media podcast
we're going to be talking about some
hardcore YouTube advice that you need to
know whether you're just starting your
journey as a content creator whether you
already have a lot of Revenue as a
business owner and you want to take
advantage of being a part of the crater
economy being a YouTube Creator an
additional write-offs that are
accessible to you we're going to talk
about credit and how you can not get
sued or at least have added layers of
protection there's probably no control
ultimately over that but I'm excited
because our guest today is Tommy
Thornburg and he's the president of
prime Corporate Services we've been
partnered with prime corporate services
for a while because because as you know
we're helping creators become really
business-minded content creators and
trying to help you get smart with the
stuff that not a lot of people are
talking about and so under his
leadership PCS has helped over a hundred
thousand entrepreneurs structure their
businesses properly and so this is going
to be a power packed episode so I'm
super fired up to have Tommy on the show
Tommy how's it going I'm doing great
thanks so much for having me everything
you said I couldn't agree more personals
personal business is business and it's
not what you make it's what you keep
that's what we want to focus on I love
it and so uh we're gonna get into so
many tactical tips about taxes and even
setting up an LLC and why some of those
things are important but I heard a quote
from you that said everyone in the U.S
should be self-employed at some level
why do you believe that so there's
there's over 70 000 pages of a tax code
right and I've got the full team of CPAs
and the full team of attorneys but I'm
an entrepreneur and I'm an investor at
heart a lot of those tax codes are meant
to benefit investors and benefit
entrepreneurs so the reason that I say
that is without a side hustle or without
a side business or without full-time
self-employment you're leaving money on
the table by not utilizing the tax code
that's ultimately there for you that's
powerful and so we this this is one of
the things we're passionate about here
at think media because one of the
coolest and really newest side hustles
is this whole crater economy thing in
fact signal fire did a report that the
fastest growing small business type is
people that are like becoming content
creators and of course that could be on
Tick Tock or Instagram there's all
different forms bloggers and people
maybe doing online businesses for us
people are taking their YouTube channels
and monetizing them in multiple
different ways so so when do you really
what's kind of the mindset shift because
I think for some that are doing a side
hustle they may have a block between
thinking I'm really self-employed I
really have a business what is the right
mindset for somebody working a nine to
five job to start shifting into that
self-employed or more entrepreneur
mindset yeah great question I mean
there's here's here's one thing that
I'll tell everybody is there's no tax
code that says that you have to be good
at business no one would be in business
everyone's got their struggles right but
there is a tax code that says if you
show the intent
to generate income and to treat and
operate as a business now you open the
doors to play by the rules to utilize
all of these additional deductions so
it's a biased opinion but in my opinion
as soon as you have the intention to be
self-employed as soon as you have an
idea of the content that you want to
create
structure yourself as a business if if
you treat something like a hobby it's
going to cost you money like a hobby but
when you treat something like a business
you reap the rewards of what businesses
have to offer so I would say from the
very beginning legitimize yourself as a
business and as a business owner yeah I
love that so set it up right and what
we're ultimately going to be tapping
into is some potential to put more money
in our pockets ultimately now I know
that sometimes there's a place where
people tune out because you're like you
think about taxes it's something you
want to just forget about not pay
attention to but it's actually one of
the highest expenses that we have as
humans period like we get taxed from a
lot of different angles and so there's a
lot of opportunities there I want to
Circle back to this later on in the
episode but what is just some brass tax
benefit that someone could be getting
let's say they're working and making you
know sixty to eighty thousand dollars a
year in some kind of nine to five or
some kind of a corporate job and maybe
they start a side hustle and there's
some extra money coming in but maybe
it's not even coming in yet you know
it's it's a few years of just investing
in their business they're buying camera
gear they're investing in online
education online courses they're getting
smarter they're trying to write off
their Studio what are some of the things
that they could just write off like a
quick list and what is the net result of
that because the math calculations hurt
my brain you know could you start
putting a few hundred dollars back in
your pocket a few thousand dollars back
in your pocket try to make that simple
yeah I love it let me kind of give a
visual for everybody as well hopefully
this helps when you have the the job I
believe they say just over broke right
isn't that what they what they say that
stands for uh when you have the j-o-b
you go to work they take taxes out of
your paycheck they give you what's left
and then you pay your bills and save
money spend money on what you choose the
beauty of being self-employed is you go
generate your own income you reinvest
back into your business to help you grow
and to help you scale and then you pay
taxes on what's left so the beauty of
that being flipped upside down is when
you're self-employed it gives you the
control to invest into yourself and to
invest into your business while really
intermingling a lot of what we call
anyways expenses right bills things that
you're going to pay anyways your phone
bill your internet bill your power bill
portions of your rent or your mortgage
for the home office it looks like you're
in a home office or an office space that
you could write off the square footage
right did you pay for a course do you
have subscriptions here is when when you
think to yourself how do I know if
something is business related how do I
know if this is tax deductible ask
yourself this question question
is it ordinary or necessary for your
business if you're a content creator
purchasing a camera becomes a necessary
expense and then it starts to get fun
where Sean if you and I were to go to an
event and go to lunch together that's
not necessary for us to enjoy each
other's company and to talk about
business but it's an ordinary expense
that becomes deductible so a lot of
people watching this will be considered
self-employed
home-based entrepreneurs and there's
over
250 different deductible expenses with
that title alone so a lot a lot of great
things you can do tax-wise I love that
and actually we'll Circle back on this
as well but you know as a partner with
uh Prime corporate services at
thinkprimellc.com you can actually do a
free call they will set up an LLC for
you for free of course there's local
potential local state fees and whatnot
but they'll do a free consult and one of
the big Keys is getting experts around
you and getting information to even see
what could you qualify for what is the
best positioning for you what are some
things you're not taking advantage of I
know for me I was shocked by essentially
how much money I was leaving on the
table but also just how much money I was
giving to the IRS and I'm not talking
about today in in where think media is
now a multi-million dollar business I'm
talking about back when I was doing a
side hustle I was working full-time at a
church doing some freelance video work
um working on my YouTube channel and
there was so many opportunities to save
more money and to also be set up
um better and so again all those details
will be in the show note show notes but
let's talk about that why is it
important to
get set up properly with an LLC or some
kind of other corporate structure yeah I
love this question I'd like to share a
story of a client that we worked with
last year actually that's really
powerful on someone that just had a W-2
income so last year they wanted to start
an online business and they made 55 500
of W-2 income and because when you're
single all you get is a standard
deduction 12
950. if you're married it's a little bit
more but this individual was single so
they're limited to that standard
deduction if they were to just go
through the motions of that 55 500
Monday through Friday they would have
been looking at just over nine thousand
dollars in taxes on just their federal
taxes that doesn't even include the
state tax that they were looking at so
this particular individual we set up
their business we showed that legal
start we showed the intent to treat an
OP operate as a business last year
unfortunately no money was made all year
last year they were still in the
preparation phase but they wrote off
startup expenses they wrote off
organizational expenses and it saved
them over five thousand dollars in taxes
simply by setting up the business
showing the business related expenses
and now they're already off to a great
start this year they're up they're
generating income just an awesome
individual and a really cool example of
it doesn't matter how much money you
make or it doesn't matter if you're just
getting started self-employment is for
everybody and the opportunity is endless
when you're in the US and when you have
this uh ability and the platform like
you do with social medias and all these
other platforms yeah it's why Financial
education is so important because okay
this person is going to pay nine
thousand dollars if they lived in
California uh or somewhere else with
state tax that's higher you're going to
pay even more than that in tax and and
then that money is just going away
you're losing the power to actually
deploy that on on something that could
help build your future so as instead
you're now starting a business you're
starting a self-employed you're starting
the side hustle and for everybody
listening and watching this you know
there's actually even in the past you
could go through the cross your t's
Dodge your eyes and show how starting a
YouTube channel is like starting a
little Media company and and it's it's a
you know it's a legitimate business but
10 years ago you know there might have
been a little more scrutiny today is no
question like it's just such a common
thing for people to be working from home
uh making a living or making extra
income from this so so you start that
thing and instead of giving that five
thousand dollars saved right to just the
IRS to I don't know how you feel about
how the government treats our money I'm
happy to prepare my fair share of taxes
but I'm still trying to pay as little as
possible because what I mean what what
we see is that money in the hands of
hard-working creators and entrepreneurs
listening to this is better deployed and
more efficient efficient stewarded and
certainly some of the outrageous
spending of the government and so
without getting too far down that rabbit
Hall the point is keep the money in your
pocket and then start building something
and so now you're able to buy a camera
and get that office going and and get
that computer and the video editing and
get this stuff happening but then you're
also investing in these assets to really
start building a life in a business on
your own terms and uh I just get so
excited about this because I was even
coaching our team recently where I'm
like listen I know you all want me to
pay you more money and uh that you might
say like I'm the reason for your
struggles the think media team but I was
like which as you perform and we're a
meritocracy of course we want to give
good raises and stuff but one of the
most valuable things that I also hope I
can give you is a financial education
because it's also how you're using your
money are you are you using it
intelligently are you and we try to have
that entrepreneur Spirit here
intrapreneur Spirit even on our team
most of our of our think media team
members they've got their own YouTube
channel Kyle Anderson is is actually
where our other studio is here in Vegas
it's still a home office but we rent it
from him he treats the income as rental
income he set up his own entity and so
it's a whole different way of thinking
that's actually putting a lot more money
in his pocket so even the way things are
set up could be hurting you or therefore
really a lack of how things are set up
so get specifically into uh why even
just having an LLC could be good you
already mentioned getting your structure
letting the government know that you
have intent to operate a business but
there's also 76 lawsuits being filed
every single minute in the United States
not an out every like as we talk on this
podcast people are suing other people
like crazy and of course that's
anybody's free will to do and it's not
that you could be even necessarily well
maybe you got you're the expert on this
there's things you could do to maybe
avoid getting sued but no matter what
happens you still may get sued so what's
the point of maybe or what's some
opportunity we have to actually protect
ourselves and to maybe be more private
and to actually prepare ahead of time so
that should something like that end up
happening we don't get crushed or we
don't get derailed or our savings and
our families uh you know savings account
or the assets and things we've worked so
hard for could be taken away from us if
we don't have things set up right break
that down Tommy yeah it's a it's a very
Sioux happy world that we are living in
very very litigious Society right and
Sean I'm sure you've heard this from a
lot of very successful people that
you've spoken with and events and
masterminds that you've spoken at a lot
of very successful people say you're not
in business until you've been in a
lawsuit
and as much as I hate that as depressing
as that is it's true personal is
personal business is business so a lot
of times people will say to me Tommy I
don't know if I want to set something up
until I generate income or what do I
have to protect here's a couple rude
reality statistics that I think are very
important for entrepreneurs to
understand you are 300 times less likely
to be audited by the IRS
when you have a business entity in place
that alone for me says worth it right
now you get to open to open the doors to
all these additional deductions but to
really simplify it down when you set up
a business entity there's three things
that you should keep in mind
number one is privacy and protection as
an entrepreneur you deserve to have
privacy you don't have to have your
address listed on your State website
there's ways that we can make that
private for you by utilizing registered
agents so having the privacy and having
the protection of separating your
personal and your business is the number
one benefit of having an LLC number two
is tax benefits
profit or loss right good or bad profit
or loss you want to put yourself in a
better position so from A Loss
standpoint any of those expenses that
you've already made the phone the
internet the power the camera
capture those as business related
expenses to make those deductible from a
profit standpoint here's where it starts
to get excited these are good problems
to have as you start to generate income
usually we'll say 50 to 100
000 or more
we can simply change the LLC so that
it's taxed as an S corp
that then allows you to pay yourself a
salary or a distribution but it also
allows you to avoid half of your
self-employment tax
which is Medicare Social Security ends
up saving you about seven percent it's a
huge benefit you make a hundred thousand
dollars I'm confident Sean you're going
to do a better job with seven thousand
than handing it over to Good Old Uncle
Sam but once again we won't get
political there so the third thing
is showing yourself as a legitimate
business not only to your clientele just
like you want to do business with
legitimate companies so does your client
tell and then a step further from a
legitimacy standpoint one of the things
that we really focus on helping our
clients is showing themselves as a
legitimate business to Banks and lenders
as well so that down the road or even
now if you want to go get business
credit or corporate funding banks are
much more likely to work with businesses
that have their ducks in a row that have
crossed the t's dot the eyes than they
are an individual off the street so
those are the three areas privacy and
protection tax benefits profit or loss
and showing yourself as a legitimate
business that's super powerful and you
know I definitely want to recommend that
uh if you're listening to the think
media podcast it's definitely worth your
time to connect with Tommy and his team
they've got CPAs and accountants and
attorneys that help people set this up
and even if you're just starting out
there's so many benefits for you but I
also want to just speak to you if you're
listening to this you're earning you
know 50k but if you're earning closer to
six figures and a lot of our community
is earning six and multiple six figures
chances are you were just losing a ton
of money you're just inefficiently uh to
taxes and even just that pivot to
getting an S corp set up this is one of
the things that literally changed uh
Sonia my wife and I's life we're the
co-founders of our company so I mean if
you're making 100K a year and you get
this set up properly and you start
having that seven percent back in your
pocket that's seven thousand extra
dollars to again deploy how you want to
gives you more reach gives you you could
hire help uh you know part-time you hire
some virtual assists you start
Outsourcing some things reinvest in more
gear and then it kind of all compounds
because all of the things that you're
reinvesting in your business are also
compounding write-offs but simply just
to have more or gunpowder seven per
seven thousand dollars more at 100K
level a lot of a lot of you listening to
this you know you're doing 150 250 300
and and then things even get more
interesting so I just want to definitely
recommend connect with Tommy uh and the
team over there uh
thinkprimellc.com or check out the show
notes that gives you the opportunity to
uh schedule a free call just to uh
connect with them but I want to talk a
little bit about
um uh specifically how online
entrepreneurs can protect themselves you
already talked about registered agent
you touched a little bit on privacy
but as we're speaking really to the US
here there's different things in
different states right so the I think
the problem that people could fall into
is they may just go to some
website to set up their LLC you know you
do like Legal Zoom or something like
that but the weakness is if you're not
actually getting you're getting
generalized information not specialized
information obviously we can't touch
everything but what are the differences
between maybe some different state taxes
different laws different things that are
happening that that most people don't
really know about that could hurt people
yeah it's a great question I mean you
hit it right on the nail not all states
are created equal when it comes to
corporate law that's just the rude
reality right and when uh Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton were going against
each other during the presidential race
I remember I was watching and I'm like
they're yelling at each other back and
forth about tax evasion and shell
companies and I'm sitting there thinking
you guys are talking about the same
thing right so regardless of what side
you're on it's expensive to run
campaigns so a lot of these tax codes
aren't going to change the benefit
investors and entrepreneurs but Delaware
Nevada Wyoming they are considered
corporate Haven States and what I mean
by that is they are more favorable
towards business owners than they are
consumers not all states are that way we
know a lot of the ones that aren't right
but the beauty of these states and I'll
just use myself as the example here I
have a holding or a parent company
that is based out of Wyoming and the
reason that I do that is it gives me
some additional privacy and some
additional protection where my name and
my address is not public information
from that Wyoming or that holding
company some of you are going to have
multiple streams of income or some of
you already have multiple streams of
income where whether you're Consulting
whether you're content creating whether
you get into real estate you can have
all of these subsidiaries or all of
these operating companies owned by that
parent or that holding company so that's
giving you the additional level of
privacy and the additional level of
protection that ultimately becomes a
massive benefit as you grow and as you
scale and to your point earlier I mean
as you start to generate more money
those are good problems to have but
they're still problems
right one of the big biggest expenses
any entrepreneur will intake is their
taxes so if you're tracking your
expenses if you have some strategy
throughout the year unfortunately the
way the tax code is set up is kind of
like a use it or lose it if you're a lot
of wealthy people invest into real
estate not necessarily because they even
want to purchase real estate but because
it's such an amazing tax benefit so once
again good problems to have but the more
that you're aware of them for your
situation the easier it is to win at
this whole game of taxes yeah and I like
that you touched you know you hit
privacy of course because of our
litigious society and a lot of angles
like that what's interesting about
content creators though is I think many
of them want an added level of privacy
in terms of sometimes people are not
using their full name they'll use a
different name they definitely want to
keep their address private they want to
keep these different things private and
when we're just starting up a company
our data could be online for all kinds
of reasons but one of which my might
just be because we just have a home
office and we haven't really thought
through some of this structure and so I
love how you're talking to the Practical
you know aspects of this just getting
started but especially as things scale
and it makes me think that's why I'm
passionate about this topic for our
community in particular because I've
just watched it happen so many times
people have joined our program called
video ranking Academy they have never
posted a video or they just barely
started on YouTube and I think about
Mary's Nash she's at 850 000 subscribers
now she's 65 she lives in a rural town
in Texas she's doing cooking videos in
her kitchen she's going to hit a million
subscribers it's absolutely insane and
she's got affiliate money coming in and
YouTube ad Revenue coming in and you
know as you kind of alluded to uh the
you know as the philosopher and Prophet
Notorious BIG once said Mo Money Mo
Problems so that's happening to a lot of
our creators and so getting things set
up right at the start in terms of uh
even to we want to our friends Ryan
Pineda who I know is also a friend of
you guys as well uh just smart people in
a circle thinking about he's been a huge
influence of thinking about real estate
and cost sag and bonus depreciation and
and we have because we've continued to
meet people like you been able to not to
avoid the problems or solve the problems
no money no problems we're solving them
because we're getting wisdom and we're
learning about some of these things
which I want to go back to taxes and I
want to kind of actually just go to 101.
what are like the first couple steps
um you know the stats say one in three
businesses are overpaying on their taxes
even if you're not Incorporated yet
right you're overpaying on your taxes if
you're listening to this chances are
there's probably some opportunities for
you but uh many 2000 they did this
survey of 2000 small companies and on
average they overpaid 11 638 dollars was
what this study showed that was that was
an average Across America and that has a
lot of overpaying but I know this is a
point of stress you're listening to this
you're like oh man you know I know I
could be doing this better but Tommy
maybe simplify it for us what is kind of
just like the first steps to make sure
we don't overpay on our taxes yeah
that's I I didn't even answer your last
question I went on a rant of my own I
apologize but there's a couple ways you
have options when setting up an LLC
right you can set it up yourself and
just go to the State website
the problem with that is all you're
doing is paying a state and a filing fee
and likely filling out your own
documentation you can hire an attorney
which is great that way it's specific
with Articles of Incorporation and
operating agreements to content creation
or whatever business you're in or you
can use one of these Services that's
done with you and I would say that's
what prime Corporate Services is is a
service that can help you and tailor it
to your specific situation of not only
the type of business that you're
operating But A to Z all the
documentation being legally prepared for
your type of business so I think there's
a massive benefit in having some
assistance especially with the
discounted rates that we offer on the
entity setup but from a tax savings
standpoint there are two recommendations
I will give any and all entrepreneurs
number one
track your expenses please the best way
and the easiest way to beat the IRS our
head CPA says death by a thousand paper
cuts you don't remember what you ate for
lunch last week
nor will you in a month but if you track
those expenses throughout the course of
the year that are ordinary or necessary
for your business it's going to make it
a lot easier to keep more money in your
corner so number one track your expenses
whether it's an Excel spreadsheet
QuickBooks a tax app a tax software or
maybe once you get to the point where
you hire a full-time bookkeeper those
are all excellent options to track your
expenses ninety percent of people or
businesses that get audited lose that
audit because they don't have an alibi
around the expense right people will
write off mileage with their vehicle
with no tracking of mileage that's
business related it's an instant loss so
if you're tracking those expenses it
does make it a lot easier to win number
two hire a professional to file your
taxes
there's a lot of accountants and a lot
of CPAs that don't file their own taxes
because you are your worst defense right
attorneys hire attorneys to represent
themselves because emotion is involved
if you hire a professional if you hire a
CPA you now have a second set of
eyeballs that could oversee the
deductions that you feel are business
related and in a worse case scenario if
there was to be an audit or if there was
a question from the IRS you have someone
that can represent you so as long as
you're tracking your expenses as long as
you're staying open-minded about what is
and is not business related the beauty
of this type of business your personal
and your business life are pretty
intermingled
so there's a lot of deductions that are
going to become business related
of things that you're doing on your
daily life anyways and I think that's
the beauty of this type of business and
why it continues to become so popular
yeah you know uh it is inspiring to look
at the opportunities for Content
creators I talked to the co-author of
our book YouTube Secrets uh Benji Travis
all the time about this him and his
family are vloggers and because they're
daily vloggers their life is very much a
an ongoing film and so they they
definitely one of the biggest tips I
also learned was this idea of
percentages I used to think you know
okay well if I ever take my car to the
grocery store and I don't use it for a
business thing then I just can't write
it off at all and Andy and I learned
that it's like no okay what about is it
reasonable is it ordinary necessary that
a portion of and so maybe there's
certain rooms in the house that you're
not writing off but for them their
entire home is a movie set you know it's
an entire home is the the A Home of
their content of course traveling in
trips is actually ordinary and necessary
for influencers and then of course you
know I I get excited because this past
week in Kyle and I went to social media
marketing world and uh to we were
filming podcasts out there and so we
ultimately of course were writing off
it's work but we're in San Diego we're
on the waterfront we're hanging out
we're sipping coffee at Copa Vida and
achilles coffee shop again essential
write-offs because we got to drink the
coffee to get ready just the meals and
whatnot and and work trip we had to hit
new Nobu up and I don't know you know no
it was another level but he had to got
to eat something and so we're in San
Diego we're on the water we're filming
videos we're hanging out we're also
going on walks and you know just
checking out the city and and and
starting to start to think about this
lifestyle this kind of content creation
lifestyle there's so many things that
end up being a write-off and we're at a
for us I think the tax bracket but I
always think about getting a 37 percent
uh discount on a lot of the things that
were doing to your point that would be
something that we'd want to do anyways
and of course this is all work related
but the fact that we could turn our
passion or our Hobbies into legitimate
businesses then it's just super exciting
times but you brought up something
that's so important hire a professional
probably one of the biggest mindsets I
want to attack here in the think media
podcast is this idea of penny pinching
and thinking small
so many people when they're starting is
there may be afraid instead of investing
in email marketing software and a CRM
because it's going to cost 30 bucks a
month they're just like you know I'm
going to code my own WordPress thing and
get a bunch of free plugins and use an
external hard drive to be my email
server I'm like what the heck are you
talking about like that's like it's only
going to take me two weeks to set it up
and it's going to be an absolute
Nightmare and it has nowhere near the
technology like what what are you
talking about or I've seen people who
again their core business has nothing to
do with legal with setting up entities
with taxes but they're like I'm going to
be my own bookkeeper I'm going to file
my own taxes I'm going to do all this
kind of stuff these are people I know
personally and people in our community
and I'm like you are you have the wrong
mindset and even if they can prove no
this is how much money I Penny pinched
here and this is what I did over here
like man you're thinking too small what
is your Genius Zone and how can you try
and delegate everything else so you can
go make more money and one of my mentors
Brett Johnson said scared money don't
make money you're over here penny
pinching trying to do all this kind of
stuff and then the way you're trying to
save is by doing something you're not
the best at or you're not an expert at
or that also doesn't give you life it
doesn't give you energy and so for for
my wife and I I mean we're small town
kids college dropouts we had to like
attack this mindset because we were she
runs she runs our finances she's our CFO
today but more than ever before even
though she has grown her skills we work
with more professionals we lean on other
experts because even if we're good we're
not great and so we ultimately are
trying to delegate to experts and what
we've discovered is that sometimes so
we'll even talk about this because we're
we came from such a small town like you
could you know shout and talk to the
entire town is only like you know 100
now you know it's Arlington Washington
years ago we were born in Seattle
in this very rural town and so it's been
hard to break off the mindset of like oh
you know a few hundred dollars here or a
few thousand dollars here but I'm like
but but honey like let's look at the Top
Line rev that we're doing and let's look
at the more we free at my time or your
time we can actually go earn more and
recover so much peace of mind and Sanity
why do we want to do these different
things I just want to encourage you
you're if you're listening to this
scared money don't make money and that
applies not just this topic I mean if
you're put putting off one piece of
software that would help you go ten
times faster help you regain 10 times
more peace and give you 10 times more
Focus so you can do the thing you're
good at that you actually love and enjoy
doing then your macro gonna be so much
further along than people that get stuck
in that penny pinching mindset so what
do you think about this Tommy have you
seen that for entrepreneurs it just kind
of hesitate like Ma I mean it might be
expensive to hire a professional and it
it's less expensive than people think
but kind of in the short term it's it's
like you're trying to save pennies while
you're leaving dollars or Benjamins on
the table that you could be accessing if
you delegated some of this stuff have
you seen this Tommy I love it I
everything that you just said I couldn't
I'm over here just nodding my head like
a bobble doll because I couldn't agree
more it's uh I've been self-employed
since I was 18 years old and my claim to
fame I have never owned a lawnmower and
the reason I think that's important is
where is your time best spent right my
time's not best spent mowing my lawn I
have someone do that for me now I think
that's cool but last night I'm actually
at a hotel to your point if I travel
here the hotel all of these things are
tax deductible expenses I'm here to work
I went to my mentor's house last night
and we had dinner and as I'm walking
around his house I'm like what does it
take to upkeep this place he said 10
full-time people
I was like I got to get over my
lawnmower story that's way cooler I
gotta I have to think bigger I'm in the
same setting right we uh we started
Prime Corporate Services 10 years ago
and we had four people we currently have
just about 200 employees at the time of
filming this video I never thought that
would happen I still think it's crazy
when I really break it down but there
have been so many instances that because
I didn't hire the right person or
because I tried to save a couple of
bucks on a software or a CRM or a system
that I move slower how much quicker
could I have moved into the areas of
opportunity where my time is best spent
to better the client experience to
better the client journey to provide a
better overall situation it's not only
selfish of me
but it's selfish to other people that
you're not doing that to save your time
to focus on what your Genius is or what
your passion is and uh there's no reason
to pick up pennies instead of stepping
over dollars is another one I think is
good to reference yeah I love it Tommy's
super powerful well as we land the plane
if uh people want to connect with you at
Prime Corporate Services the URL is
thinkprimellc.com and that's in the show
notes but when people go to that page
they're able to to schedule a call what
exactly is going to happen there if
people want to uh take action and get
some of these things set up what's the
opportunity so
thinkprimellc.com what I would tell
everybody is just remember that that
consultation is for you we've built
Prime Corporate Services with the
thought in mind of helping people by
actually helping people crazy right so
when you take advantage of that hour
call
it's going to be 45 minutes to an hour
of you and one of our direct advisors
and what I would recommend is go into
that call and let us know are you brand
new if you're brand new say hey I'm just
getting started I'm brand new break
these things down for me like a third
grader because they're not exciting
topics but some of you may be more
experienced some of you may have
multiple businesses and multiple streams
of income which is great
let us know that going into it so that
you get the most value
we'll talk to you about your entity
structure we'll talk to you about how to
build additional business credit and
corporate funding we can help you with
filing your taxes or preparing your
taxes
and then as you build wealth we can even
tie it all together with estate planning
from a legacy play as well but please
please please remember that that call is
for you I want you to get the most out
of that free consultation schedule the
call take advantage of the free
consultation and let us know what we
could do to help you better your
business for the future and have a solid
foundation to build your Empire off of
long term I love it and Tommy we're
super pumped about you know I met the
CEO of prime Corporate Services uh
Stephen Harward last year we've hung out
a couple of times and it's
revolutionized think media you guys
think different you uh you think bigger
and I have been learning
um especially in the last 24 months at
think media that I gotta get around the
right people and what I've been talking
to my wife and our team about is I want
to get around experts I just as soon as
you start one of the most dangerous
places we can be is thinking we know or
getting comfortable or complacent and
man when we just stay humble we ask a
lot of questions we go into
opportunities like this where we can say
it ma'am hear exactly where I'm at but I
I just assume you know show me my blind
spots show me the opportunities and man
the how that's multiplied our success
and our acceleration at think media has
been massive so I appreciate everything
you were doing your guys's team and the
culture there it's so rad and just so
grateful it's so cool too to see I know
friends like Ryan Pineda and Pace morby
different people that are just kind of
in this circle really smart you know
humble awesome people that are helping
us be better at think media so super
excited about everything y'all are doing
and uh check out the show notes right
for all resources and you can also
connect with Tommy there if Tommy people
want to reach out are you on social
media I just followed you on LinkedIn
finally to get connected over there but
are you very active on social I
appreciate it it's Prime Corporate
Services everything Instagram social
media media everything Facebook Prime
Corporate Services
um give us a like give us a follow it's
actually really cool we try and give you
a a tax tip every Tuesday it's uh it's
common for people to get a full year and
then all of a sudden tax times here
again if we can give you a tax tip
that'll benefit your business every
Tuesday we try and drop something to
keep you thinking about us and about
your taxes so Prime Corporate Services
give us a like give us a follow and
reach out with any questions we
seriously are here to help Tommy thank
you